I believe the Earth is round I believe
the Earth is round I believe the Earth
is round I believe the Earth is round I
believe the Earth is round I believe the
Earth is round I believe the Earth is
[Music]
round so just as a as a you know po who
here believes the Earth is
flat yeah raise your hands right now any
of you guys take
flights I think we've all I would have
to assume everyone at some point in
their life can me is it a thing do you
guys hear about Flat Earth out there I
mean is I've heard like some things I
never believe they existed to be honest
I was like there's no way you think this
I feel like I've only seen it on like TV
or like movies like I've never perceived
someone in real life being a flat Earth
I was very surprised just to find out
somebody in here who was a flat earther
in the first place honestly I thought
that the flat earther would be someone
that like didn't go to college so that's
what I was going to I was also going to
say single and live with your
parents right so like my image of flat
earther is like just a generic white guy
I picture somebody who's a little bit
lanky who wears
um t-shirts okay should we maybe start
by doing like what does everyone do or
what does everyone study or something
like that um I went to UC Berkeley and
studied biology but now I'm a twitch
streamer I have a bachelor's and Masters
in mechanical engineering I study
sociology and Kinesiology I work for an
electronics company we um we develop uh
products mostly that is used for with
the Air Force and government got my
bachelor's in psychology and then I'm
currently at UCLA getting my PhD in
Neuroscience I'm currently getting my BS
in microbiology and I'm Premed I have
had a few careers I was a high school
English teacher I was a software
engineer and now I'm a restaurant tour
so like what what evidence is there that
the Earth is flat or I guess round like
what why are you a round earther yeah
yeah yeah why why are you around Earth I
like there's a lot of things regarding
like whether the Earth is round you know
like obviously people have traveled
around the world and if the Earth was
flat somebody would have fallen off like
secondly also every single planet is
round so why would every planet plus the
Stars be round but Earth is flat just
also third when you look out in the
Horizon you can only see about 12 miles
out if the Earth was flat you could see
out forever hypothetically so the Earth
is round in my opinion that was a lot of
a lot of
points
it's a little suspicious over
there to argu my point pretty well I
don't know she might be
overom I mean obviously like if you're a
flat earther you got to know the the
talking points for the router if I were
to add anything I would just say like I
mean we also have like photographic
evidence I I feel like trying to come up
with Arguments for flatter just just to
spice up the conversation I mean they
could fishey the photos they could like
yeah they Photoshopped it you know
that's a solid point you know that's
that could be photoshopped I just think
it's funny that this is a
thing I was a software engineer we did
geom mapping okay so we had to map
distances between addresses and uh
there's a thing called spherical
geometry the actually the ancient Greeks
figured that out there were enough of
them that walked from one town to
another they're like this this is not
exactly where we think it should be and
they were clever enough that into the
thousands of years BC they knew that the
Earth was round also I I always wonder
like is there an edge like have you guys
seen like Pats of the Caribbean you know
when they fall and they go to the edge
of the Earth and you know like I that's
how I Envision Flat Earth is believe and
then also what happens with night and
day like if it was flat and then the sun
like how does how does that work I just
I know I haven't done enough research on
flat earthers when you travel I mean you
can travel both ways around right you
can go one way or the other to get to
the other side of the world like I've
flown to Shanghai so often and I've also
been to Europe so like at some point I
should have fallen off right like
theoretically right if there's an edge
you should have at least seen yeah wait
are any of you guys religious yeah I'm
Hindu so I'm not religious I'm I'm
Catholic Protestant I don't like the
term religion but like a belief yeah I'm
a Believer I prefer the term theist
myself I'm an atheist yeah yeah I don't
I don't really ReliOn
gocha whoa where you going what's the
rush oh you know I'm just running away
from the comment section of this video
all this running has me starving oh well
do you want to go get something to eat I
was just about to go get lunch no I'm
good I've been meal prepping thanks to
factor oh aren't they sponsoring this
video yep Factor makes meeting your
nutrition goals easier than ever by
delivering fresh never Frozen dietitian
approved meals right to your doorstep
I'm always on the go so I barely have
time to cook with Factor I've been able
to skip an extra trip to the grocery
store and save all that chopping prep
and cleanup time their meals are ready
in Just 2 minutes so all I have to do is
heat and enjoy then get back to my me
time factor is also super flexible with
meal plans ranging from 4 to 18 meals
per week you can easily adjust your
order size enjoy with loved ones and
even skip a week whenever you need to my
current fave is a sundried tomato
chicken but I'm dying to check out some
limited time only meals from their fall
flavors menu it's giving Autumn and I
need to satisfy my fall craving so if
you're looking to find that balance and
need to get your meals in no matter what
lifestyle you live head to factor75.com
or click the link below and use the code
Jubilee 50 to get 50% off your first
Factor box thanks so much to factor for
sponsoring this episode now let's get
back to the
[Music]
video he is an English teacher and if
you do literature you must be a freeth
thinker and your mind must be able to
push the
imagination when he started to defend
flat earthers in the beginning I was
like hm plus he also looks the role I'm
sorry to say but he also kind of looks
like a flat
arur why do you think they were
suspicious of you well I'm a little bit
older than most of them and I have a
little bit more of a variety of a career
can I ask what like political
affiliation everyone has yeah sure um
I'm unaffiliated I don't like politics
so yeah same uh I guess I would I would
lean more is like a liberal I feel like
I'm privileged enough to not be into
politics like that I mean same I don't
want to like it disree with what saying
but it's true so well now I don't want
to say anything
because I mean if I had to pick a team
that i' I I I'm definitely conservative
um but through considering things
logically I'm I'm more of a I say I'm a
left leaning moderate yeah um I think I
lean more liberal but obviously making
sure to think about things and context
to reason things up wait okay I have a
question what's the defense you can make
for flat earthers I always like to like
look at the other opposition to make a
conclusion you know I I will say I this
is probably going to like make you guys
think that I'm the mo but um I will say
that I'm not 100% sure we went to the
moon so I'm not I'm not like I'm I'm I'm
not 100% convinced that we've gone to
the moon so I don't know maybe if like
if we didn't go to the moon what else
could the government be lying to us and
ask be lying to us about what's your
reasoning behind that though I mean like
a lot I guess a lot of things just seem
suspicious to me when I like when I
first heard I was like oh cool that we
went to the moon but then I'm like well
we went to the Moon with very little
Tech like like the tech that like in the
during the Cold War and then also just
like the flag was waving which I mean I
guess really doesn't make any sense
considering there's no wind in space but
um and then like also there was Shadows
which also doesn't really make sense
because there
the the way it was but yeah I mean yeah
so I just had a bunch of questions
that's it
interesting% but like you I also believe
I also agree that we wanted to win
certain aspects of the Cold War I we or
another so were any of you guys like I
mean I did vote Ryan out so was there
anyone else that was like suspicious to
anyone I will say I I I voted for for
Georgia I apologize I also did yeah but
yeah just because you started off
defending them a little bit so I was
like hm yeah I think it's maybe like
scientificity I mean I mean trying to
figure it out yeah yeah and then also I
mean you're conservative and a lot of
listen listen I mean a lot of
white-winged individuals believe some
pretty insane things like Trump is still
president far right wing let me they
look far right can be pretty crazy
thinkers so I'm not sure where on the
political Spectrum you are but you say
conservative and I get a little I guess
a TI
queasy just a bit worried I'm interested
like how come you I mean I get that you
were trying to like see from the other
perspective but like what compelled you
to like defend flat earthers um so from
a scientific aspect I think everything
needs to be considered uh what would you
say if someone dude showed up and said
you know what instead of like things
being normal like they are space bends
and time is flexible what do you think
of
that 100 years ago I'm I'm surprised
anyone took up the idea at all but
that's kind of considered the norm um
for today I might not be a flat earther
but I believe that space is
flat I don't think that time bends and
space warps um but I think there's
things that make it look like that I
just got myself voted off the show
didn't
I but I think I think that famous
scientist in the past like Albert
Einstein he he had to think freely about
how to rationalize things that couldn't
be answered at the time so so he
answered questions that no one could
answer he seems to know a lot and a lot
of flat earthers do a lot of research so
that so that they can fight and argue
their their belief do you do you not
believe that gravity bends space and
time as it's like like black hole
theories I have an entire whole
hypothesis on that I've written a bunch
of stuff personally and he please talk
about it and it it would take a long
time
do you know who the mole is comment down
below and don't forget to like And
subscribe he was so freethinking and so
willing to consider all options that I
thought his thinking could like
transcend the round earth and he could
arrive back at to the like back to the
Flat Earth conclusion
again yeah I mean if he started to doubt
whether we were on the moon or not I
feel like he would have some other
things to
doubt I voted for ik pamosa um mostly
because I thought he was going to vote
for
me uh well I mean when discussing
scientific topics uh you have to have a
degree of open-mindedness so uh kind of
digging into that I think a little deep
gave everyone the impression that I was
uh freethinking enough to be a flat
earther and be trying to hide it if you
want to keep playing because you think
the mole could still be in the Box raise
your hand one two
three that's
majority so we move on to round three
what are your guys's thoughts on climate
change I think climate change is real
and it's very scary when you look at
what's happening to an environment I
think you feel it I mean I feel like
every single year summer keeps coming
around sooner and sooner and it last a
lot longer it's I me we're hearing about
people dying of heat waves like like
it's yeah I feel like it's hard to not I
feel like at this point if you're
actively like trying to not believe that
global warming is a thing I'm like this
this Earth if you believe it around the
flat is
it's going downhill it's scary to
think about every time I think about
having kids I'm like good luck guys not
my
problem I mean honestly it is our
problem though too that's true I believe
that we have a responsibility kind of
fix it it's not we didn't start this
problem but right we could definitely
make it worse so we should how old is
everybody I'm 23 I'm 28 28 19 24 20 oh
okay so yeah genz I feel bad that we
voted out I
know I feel like I feel like as a young
group we like we're more educated so I I
feel like it's harder to like really
Point down or for one of us to really
believe yeah for sure is flat but I was
just going to say one thing I've watched
this show before and like they like to
you know throw you off by like
appearance-based
so in the best way possible you look
very sciencey I don't know I don't know
so I'm
saying I feel like your even your
educational background like fits it too
perfectly that I feel like they could
easily be like what was your educational
background again I did me for both
bachelors and Masters but he could be
like Oh I'm I'm kind of suspicious of
you too it's only due to not talking as
much you and you I mean I'll sh I'll
share
I earlier of like I don't know the mo
Landings
and that's the only reason so do you
think the Odyssey to the Titanic
happened submarine suburble trip thing
did that happen yeah do you think I
think rich white people doing dumb rich
white people things is going to happen
to AUST so for sure that definitely
happened I'm not going to lie though I
was a little suspicious of you still
kind of am I think just cuz you said you
were religious and I feel like oh okay
yeah no that's fair I will say I mean
being Indian you cannot believe in being
a flat Earth there you need to believe
in like solid both my parents are
software Engineers I cannot go believing
in flatter earth flat
[Music]
orther
our take one tin step this
and one step
forward so on the count of three raise
your hand if you want to keep playing
one two
three majority has voted not to keep
playing because they are confident that
the M's been voted out if the Box turns
green you four have correctly guessed
the mole out and will split the cash
prize if the Box turns red the mole is
still among the four of you and they
have won the cash prize to themselves
are you four
ready
one
two three oh thank
God thank you guys for all believing in
around Earth you doubted me
but so I'm going to count the three and
then the mole they step
forward
2 3
wait really I know it's
wacky are you guys surprised at all I
actually I had like all my money was on
George so I was like wait whoa the the
school teacher is the fat earther you
were a teacher at one point so for me I
was like oh well I mean he's a teacher
so he you know he wouldn't believe such
a crazy idea then here I am wrong you
had a pretty good stick with the
software engineer thing but I I can't
say any more than Vibe I had a Vibe it
was you yeah I story-wise it was with my
team of Engineers which is interesting
it's surprising how much you don't think
about certain things until you do my
fiance she's uh she's been on this
before oh okay oh
interesting which episode The Globe
birther
flatter interesting I didn't know if it
was that one but we're all taught
certain things we are whether we admit
it or not we're indoctrinated with
beliefs with certain things whether it's
religion whether it's government whether
it's what have you you know we're taught
a lot more what to think instead of how
to think if you don't want me asking do
you believe truth is subjective or
objective I definitely believe in um an
objective truth interesting yeah there's
a lot of ridicule there's a lot of hate
when people believe in something
different and I find it fascinating
really I I don't it doesn't really
bother me there's trolls out there or is
Taylor Swift would say the haters will
hate it's
fine just throw
it I'm so sorry wean we're so sorry we
clean